you talk to hundreds of people in tech
um
like what proportion of them fall into
this category where you see them as
activists who are trying to improve
things it can be hard
to identify them because i think a lot
of the executives have learned how to
talk like
they are ethical technologists um but
you really have to look at
actions i mean one of the one of the
principles i i
look at in the book is this idea of
consequentialism
of sort of me the need for technologists
to kind of
measure their success not based on how
they intended their products to work but
on
how their products actually work out in
the world when you say you know mark
zuckerberg your you know your news feed
algorithm is is
you know tearing society apart or
leading to more polarization
the fallback response is always well you
know we built this with good intentions
and what i'm trying to tell people is
like it doesn't matter like
your intentions are it's good that if
they're good
but what ultimately matters is how this
technology is applied out in the world
and you know that's a very strange
standard man like
if i'm a doctor and then i do something
messed up
and then you know it's like like
whenever i operate on the wrong leg
and then they'd be like hey that was the
wrong leg being well i intended it to be
the right leg
that's not that's not exactly like a
compelling uh
argument in just about any field right
but you hear that
all the time in tech and i think it's
really ingrained in them that as long as
you have good intentions
your job is just to create the
technology and how people use it is up
to them
[Music]
welcome back to yang speaks it's good to
be with you all hope you're all holding
up okay this is zach grauman one of the
co-hosts of yang speaks look we're gonna
do two things today
on this episode number one we've got
kevin roose joining with andrew for a
conversation kevin roose
is a new york times tech columnist and
was the first reporter
to write an article about andrew yang as
a presidential candidate
first he called him a longer than
long shot and i've joked with kevin
since then i was like thank you for
doing that because that was just
motivation he jokes
we laugh and he's like yeah maybe i
should have called him that i'm not sure
but i blew that
quote up and i put it on the campaign hq
wall and i said
team that's our floor
um and it was funny because we went from
long in the long shot to uh 538 called
as a semi-serious candidate
and then we were called a candidate by
cnn and then we were
uh a major candidate by 538 and then it
was all the crazy headlines you've seen
over the years of us running so kevin
ruth's the man who started it all
he's got some really insightful stuff on
the internet and youtube algorithms and
how they're fueling the far right and
far left
and making us more divided he's a pretty
insightful guy and andrew and him are
cut from similar cloths in that sense so
i hope you enjoy that
before to that i want to give you all a
breakdown
on the record-breaking stimulus package
that was just passed by the biden
administration
i'm going to break down exactly what's
in it and then i'm going to talk about
our opinions
the yang view so breakdown of the
american rescue plan
for coronavirus relief that was just
passed starts
right now
[Music]
[Applause]
all right what is in the new american
rescue plan just passed by the
joe biden administration the american
rescue plan is a 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill with
five main components and break them all
down very quickly number one
most importantly 1400 stimulus checks to
the people
we hope for two thousand dollars they
said it's a you know if you combine the
six hundred dollars we got earlier it's
two thousand whatever we'll take we can
get
so if you make under seventy five
thousand dollars a year
or a married couple making under a
hundred fifty thousand dollars per year
you are eligible and what does that mean
it's fourteen hundred dollars per person
and fourteen hundred dollars per
dependent so kids people that are
dependent on others
for their income according to your 2020
tax
return last year number two that's the
momentum number two
it's going to continue the 300 per week
boost to unemployment checks through
september of 2021. so if you lost your
job and you filed for unemployment
this is solid money in addition to what
you can get so normally depending on the
state you can get 100 to 500
per week in unemployment benefits and
this is 300
stacked on top of that um and then
they're going to waive your federal
income taxes on that money up to the
first
10 200 for households earning under 150
000 so if your household earns under
150k
you don't pay taxes on this money either
number three
there's a lot of tax credits here
specifically the child tax credit in
2021. so we don't love
tax credits guys i think the hardest
part of them is that you have to
actually file taxes and
have to file them right many people
don't know how to do that but is better
than nothing
so right now you can get a 2 000 tax
credit per child
up to age 17. that is gonna go up to
three thousand six hundred dollars for
children
up to age five and as much as three
thousand dollars for children
six to seventeen probably gets
complicated it's taxes but they are
expanding the eligibility here
and in the second half of the year
they're gonna give advanced payments of
this which is good one of the problems
with tax credits it's complicated and
you don't get the money for a while when
you actually need it
so ideally a lot of this is going to get
to family soon it's like a ubi
almost for families with children very
cool theoretically
they're also going to expand child and
dependent care tax credits
uh you're going to earn income tax
credits for workers without children in
2021
and then exempting student loan
forgiveness
from your income through 2025. it's a
lot of tax income and tax credit
expansions number four money to fight
the pandemic
which is big this is going to help state
schools local governments so they're
gonna have money for covid fighting so
that includes vaccine distribution
coronavirus testing contact tracing
genomic sequencing things like that and
then money for fema which is our
disaster relief organization at the
federal level which is good and then 350
billion dollars are going to states and
local governments
so that includes colleges and
universities includes our schools and
reopening them
transit agencies housing child care
providers food assistance programs
things like that and also
businesses restaurants and live venues
it includes a bailout for
multi-employer pension plans that aren't
able to make their payments to
workers during the pandemic number five
beefs up the affordable care act
regardless what you think of it it is a
healthy healthcare
millions of americans use this to get
their health care um so it's going to
increase subsidies for people
buying health on healthcare.gov through
the affordable care act marketplace
that's
billions of dollars in public health
programs and veterans healthcare and if
you
have heard of cobra which is what you um
use to keep your healthcare when you
lose your job
you're covered through september of this
year so expanding that as well so the
bottom line is guys those are your five
things
you've got your 1400 stimulus checks to
people you've got 300
per week boost to unemployment checks
you've got expanded tax credits
particularly a child tax credit you've
got
money to fight the pandemic and reopen
our schools and local governments
you've got affordable care act subsidies
and beefing that program up for people
get health care
a couple things if you want to get your
check if you've already qualified for
this and use direct deposit to file your
taxes you should get that soon as soon
as march 12th
we are gonna post this link in our
podcast description there's a site where
you can
navigate the irs and how to get your
stemmy check so get that stemi check
it's
irs.gov coronavirus slash get
dash my dash payment i'll just say from
yang and i's perspective some pros and
cons here
pros guys we freaking did something
okay you know what i'm saying we think
our government did something which is
objectively a good thing we don't
normally do things we've been very
delayed in our coronavirus response
so thank god thank heaven thank whoever
we did something
we channeled a lot of andrew yang here
it's pretty exciting there is a lot of
cash relief as i just read off so that's
exciting i feel great
as a human being in terms of the impact
we have had on our society
despite how desperate this situation is
so democrats are thrilled
um because this is a big win for joe
biden getting this done
and i think people like this by the
numbers it appears so 62 percent of
americans approve
how joe biden is handling the pandemic
that's an npr pbs poll
uh trump was at 39 for context when he
left
office 61 of americans according to cnn
approve it so there's multiple polls
saying that and the big one it seems
that most people support what's in it
even if they don't approve biden
so 85 or 75 depending the poll you're
looking at support
cash relief and tax credits and
reopening the schools and a lot of
uses of the money so i think this is
generally objectively a positive thing
so that's a big pro
a couple cons here i know i have my
libertarian republican listeners we love
you too
we are humanity first i think it's fair
i'm a little frustrated that we can get
two thousand dollar
checks but we'll take 1400 second thing
not a single republican voted for this
bill
some press outlets have called this to
end of bipartisanship i'm not sure if
that's true but that was frustrating um
which also made me frustrated because of
the negotiation tactics
used here because the house
um original bill from the democrats um
was actually more aggressive
and then they came down with a lot of
their levels to negotiate and then not a
single republican voted so what was the
point of you should have just
if you're just gonna have to force it
through you might as well get what you
want so the house originally wanted a
hundred thousand dollar income
minimum and a two hundred thousand
dollar income per couple
uh so that would have been better for
more people uh they wanted a four
hundred dollar employment bump
per week instead of 300 so that would
have been better a lot of people wanted
the 15
minimum wage hike but the republicans
were able to get that out
they had the ability to block it with a
filibuster that was too big of a
a move here so i'm not sure what you
think of the 15 minimum wage we are more
ubi than 15
minimum wage but we are pro money in
people's hands so generally for
paying workers more if you can do it
realistically but that was not included
in this package there are a lot of
headlines on it hopefully many of you
are getting a stemi check
um and hopefully it's going to good use
in a time where we all could use it so
now
sit back relax kevin roose is joining
yang speaks
[Music]
i am so excited to welcome to the
podcast my friend
the author new york times tech columnist
kevin roos
kevin welcome andrew thank you for
having me it's good to see you
it's been a while yeah it's been too
long so kevin wrote this book
i'm probably gonna do this multiple
times but it's called future proof
nine rules for humans in the age of
automation so you can see why i'm eager
to talk to kevin because this is so up
my alley
so my alley i actually even gave a
jacket quote to the book
so now it is in my interest to make sure
that it sells gajillions of copies
yeah i got the yang bump and and i see
the success of this book as a
or failure of this book as a referendum
on your uh
or failure it's true it's like everyone
just leave automation alone
love the book super excited for people
to get their hands on it but first i
want to retrace our steps a little bit
in your steps because i think you're
a great person to be delving into this
topic from both your professional
experience but also even some of your
personal origins
if you're watching uh this or listening
to this podcast you remember
the launch of my presidential campaign
there was a story in the new york times
said something like the robots are
coming uh says this guy
that was written by kevin roose kevin
roose broke the entire presidential
campaign story for the new york times in
early 2018.
yeah i still remember we um we had a
a a sort of coffee in dinan de luca
which
no longer exists in the in the bottom of
the new york times building
and uh and we had met a couple times and
kept in touch but
you you said you had something to tell
me and i was like all right he's
launching some startup he's doing some
and you you got we got there and um and
you sort of leaned in and you said like
i'm running for president and i was kind
of like president of
of what like of your co-op like of the
you know
and you said no like president of the
united states and i was just incredulous
because you had no political profile and
i was like
that's cool and like how is this
actually gonna work and then you proved
me totally wrong
um by uh or i proved you're right
because you did write the story
that's true that's true so you called me
a longer than long shot which i think
was empirically accurate
[Laughter]
you did a lot better than i thought you
were going to and i was i was
remembering this morning
uh after that story ran we were having a
a new york times tech conference out in
half moon bay california and uh you
flew out to it not as like a panelist or
a you know speaker or anything but just
as sort of an audience member and i
remember
um there was a talk going on and and you
raised your hand in the back of the room
and asked a question and you introduced
yourself and you said i'm andrew yang
and i'm
i'm running for president to give people
universal basic income
uh because of automation and there was
like polite
uh chuckling in the uh in the audience
but
it's it's amazing how much has happened
since then um and it's just been it's
been wild to watch your
your success and the success with which
you've really put this issue
on people's minds because i think before
you
started running um automation ai was
seen as like a very
niche issue that tech people cared about
but that other people didn't really know
a ton about
certainly our campaign succeeded in
mainstreaming uh the issues of
automation
and um and universal basic income
as a path forward so i'm super
grateful to everyone but i am grateful
to you kevin because it took a real
shot of journalistic judgment uh and
vision
to write that story uh i remember you
and i sat down and when when we sat down
i did not think that there a story was
going to come out of it i wasn't like
ooh
i totally got the other government he's
gonna write about this um but you had a
nose for it i remember
i think you even talked to someone on
your team maybe your editor about it and
then we're like hey
do you want to like uh do a story and
then of course at that point i was like
heck yes
um so what was that process did you end
up pitching it to someone
yeah i pitched it to my editor and i was
like this guy andrew yang
is uh is running for president because
he's worried about the robots taking all
the jobs and thinks we need
universal basic income and you know my
editor is a
very thoughtful guy was sort of like so
tell me why this
should be a story again so i had to kind
of like convince
people that it was worth their attention
because i thought you know even if
you were longer than long shot which i
thought at the time
i thought the issue was one that i had
never seen
a candidate run so squarely on this
issue of
automation of technology is sort of
changing the economy and how do we deal
with that so i just thought like i'm a
tech columnist i'm not a political
journalist
i don't you know i don't handicap races
so i was just interested from the tech
angle about the kind of way that you
were trying to draw attention to
this technology and how it was going to
impact the workforce well
grateful to you kevin grateful to your
editor
because that article really did put us
on the map um i do remember the
conference you're talking about too
and i was in the back and i did raise my
hand and i said hey i'm adrienne you're
ready for president
um uh and you're right it was not met
with raucous acclaim
i think people were like how'd this guy
sneak in
indeed security telling people privately
or running for president
is different than after an article comes
out then it's like well now i'm publicly
running for president and then
you know you um have to make that case
uh very often that was an adjustment for
me actually every stage was an
adjustment saying it privately was an
adjustment and saying it publicly was an
adjustment
yeah but now but now look at you you're
uh you're a full-fledged uh
political machine um um oh well
i guess thank you you and i knew each
other prior to that and
i think you're a singular voice on this
in part because you grew up in the
midwest
in ohio right yep you experienced or at
least saw
firsthand uh some of these impacts uh on
your hometown
yeah i grew up in in the rust belt um
my you know county was one where there
had been a lot of steel plants
and those closed up in the
you know 70s 80s 90s both because of a
combination of automation and also
offshoring and outsourcing and so it's
been a pretty economically hard hit
region by this
and that was one of the reasons i was i
was interested in it
and i was also interested because and i
don't know whether you experienced this
i'm sure you did but
the conversation about ai and automation
out here in silicon valley
is is very bipolar it's it's either
everyone thinks you know ai is amazing
and it's going to solve all our problems
and it's going to
fix climate change and cure cancer and
we're all going to sort of be in this
utopian society because ai is going to
do all our dirty work for us
or it's sort of like people are very
dystopian like you know elon musk and
people you know they think we're going
to get super intelligence that's going
to enslave us all and
it's all very far in the future the way
they talk about it and i was
struck you know when i started
researching this book of like how much
is actually going on right now like how
much displacement is happening how much
ai
is sort of working its way into our all
of our lives and so i was
trying to sort of do the micro version
of the macro argument that you had which
was like this stuff is changing the
economy
these are the policies we need including
you know ubi and other things
and i i've sort of thought of myself as
sort of the micro version of that
argument where it's like yes this stuff
is coming it's changing the economy
people are being displaced
so what can we as sort of
non-politicians as non-lawmakers
actually do about it how do we you know
how do we sort of
orient our careers how do we orient our
habits and our lives and our communities
so that this doesn't totally catch us
off guard oh
it's one reason why i appreciate your
book so much as it tries to be
useful on a personal level and also talk
about the
immediate time frame because i couldn't
agree with you more that when you talk
to people about this
even people that frankly should be very
analytical rigorous types
they have a tendency just to cut to some
extreme statement
of some god which i found
very confusing uh and
consistent when i was trying to make the
case i was making so the fact that you
ran into the same thing in some ways
doesn't surprise me but it does
discourage me because some time has
passed
yeah and that technology has gotten
better and it's gotten more applied so
there are now companies that are
automating
jobs at a furious rate and that's grown
even since the pandemic
there's been a huge uptick in sales of
automation software hardware robots
things like that so i
i don't think people fully appreciate
how quickly this is coming and in
silicon valley people
generally like to think on like a
systems level
which is part of you know what it means
to be an engineer or a technologist
but i was you know getting questions
from people like okay well what do i
tell my kid to major in in school or
like
is my job gonna get automated yeah you
are trying to be practical on a useful
level and i
i will be the first to say that one i
got that question
a lot on the trail and two that my book
does not even attempt to answer that
question
well you were taking a different
approach and i think we need both i mean
with you know i compare it to something
like
climate change where like you need
people thinking at the policy level
about you know what kind of tax
structure do we you know do we need cap
and trade do we need
you know carbon credits do we need you
know what kind of how can we address
this at the macro level
but you also need someone to be saying
you know maybe don't buy that you know
beachfront
development in miami because that's all
going to be underwater
and here are the things you can do in
your own life whether it's buying an
electric car
or something like that to sort of
decrease your own
contributions to climate change so that
was sort of the approach i took was like
the
kind of ultra personal ultra applicable
practical advice for people to deal with
this in their own lives
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's face it going to the
post office is not fun
it's terrible you have better things to
do with your time like learning to cook
which is what i'm doing in the pandemic
i made garlic mashed potatoes the other
day and they were
dynamite little soupy but very very good
but regardless
your time is more valuable and you need
to stop going the post office you need
to start looking at stamps.com so
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service
and ups right to your computer it's a
must-have for any business
whether you're a small office sending
out invoices or an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
so here's the view stop wasting time by
going to the post office and go to
stamps.com
instead there's no risk and with our
promo code yang
you get a special offer that includes a
four week trial free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
yang at stamps.com
promo code yang stance.com never go to
the post office again
[Music]
[Applause]
i think i've seen different quotes
saying something like we're going
uh forward a matter of years in a matter
of weeks or months because
of covid what have you seen
that maybe some other folks might have
read about in passing
in terms of what's happening economy
wide in the labor market
well there i think there are a couple
things happening and there are a couple
reasons behind that acceleration
one is i think the the pandemic
accelerated the demand
for robots software products p
you know factories needed to keep
producing goods even if their employees
were you know didn't want to be in the
factory
um you know fedex uh tyson the meat
processor
they lots of companies have brought in
robots to sort of meet demand
even while their employees some of them
were out sick
and then you had this the second reason
which was that the actual technology was
just moving forward i mean we've had
um this is a super fast moving area of
tech in the past 18 months we've had
new um advances in robotics i mean
the sort of robot arms that can pick
things in warehouses and that's
taken a big step forward these large
language models like gpt-3 which are
coming out of ai labs and
threatened to replace frankly me
so gbt3 it's like a natural language uh
ai that can produce simple journalistic
accounts you know
people might have seen it online yeah
not even simple journalistic accounts
the guardian
wrote an op-ed a few months ago using
gpt-3 and there was a
there was an editor's note at the end of
the article that said
this article was actually easier to edit
than a lot of op-eds that we get from
humans
um so it's it's getting fairly
sophisticated and then i think the third
thing that the pandemic did was that it
gave
corporate executives cover to do the
kinds of automation that they had wanted
to do for years but had waited on
because they didn't want to be seen as
job killers so i talked to a number of
executives and consultants who said
you know we could have automated our
call center five years ago
um but we didn't want to do that because
you know wouldn't save us that much
money and
it was you know sort of marginal but
also you know people might
our workers might get scared that their
jobs were going away
but during covid kind of all bets were
off and so a lot of companies called up
their consultants and said hey let's
let's do that automation project we
talked about
well part of it too is there were
consumer preferences where like in the
old days if you had
like the self-driving pizza delivery
vehicle uh or
the the self-checkout or the cleaning
robots then and you're a customer you're
like oh it's a little bit
uh spooky or or eerie but now you're
like oh fewer human
uh hands touched my thing like you know
that that's a win
um so i i think it gave them cover in
multiple ways
totally yeah so so mckinsey called this
the great acceleration and they said
it's
basically they revised their estimate of
how
many workers would be displaced by ai
and automation by the end of the decade
and before the pandemic it was
37 million and now they've changed that
to 45 million
another 8 million jobs thank you
mackenzie for cataloging
our disastrous times where would we be
without mckinsey telling us how bad it's
gonna get an extra eight million
jobs lost by decades and uh is enormous
um i i was struck by um what you called
uh robotic process automation or rpa
it's this very boring acronym
um but it turns out it touches a lot a
lot of things and that
uh companies are like ooh like i i can
invest in these rpa bots uh very often
um and they just end up simplifying
processes and saving money
yeah the the chapter in the book is
called beware of boring bots
because i think when we think of
automation and the the risky kinds of ai
we think about you know skynet
or you know robocop dude i had the same
freaking problem all the time on the
trail i had to constantly be like look
it's not like a robot's gonna show up to
your office and replace you
right it doesn't work quite like that
right so
and and the rpa thing is fascinating
because rpa robotic process automation
is like the most boring part of the
of the ai industry like it is it is the
least sexy
you know they don't win prizes it's
basically software
programs that can be installed inside
large corporations to do
the work that you know phil in
accounting used to do
um it can you know process invoices and
approve expense reports and
you know plug into databases think
dunder mifflin think of all the people
hanging out in that office exactly
exactly so now if they made the office
in 2021 it would just be like four rpa
bots um talking to each other
but i i was fascinated by this because i
didn't basically know it existed and i
started going to all these conferences
and talking to all these executives in
the rpa market
and they are really blunt um
about the fact that this technology is
replacing people
i mean there was one thing that was
called like the boomer remover which is
so dark
i mean i shouldn't laugh because it was
literally it's like hey we can replace
an elderly worker
yeah this was a guy i met at a cocktail
party in san francisco and he came up to
me and
introduced himself when he said you know
i've got this ai software called the
boomer remover
and it basically lets companies replace
sort of middle managers
and he was very proud of that and i was
thinking to myself like this is going to
be a total
disaster i had sort of the same feeling
that i you know i'm
i'm guessing you had early in your your
sort of conversion on this stuff where
it's like
oh man if there's one of these people
selling boomer remover software there's
got to be thousands of them
and this is happening all over the
economy and what are we going to do
about it
yeah i mean one of the moments for me
was talking to a very high-end venture
capitalist based in boston who was like
yeah
about two-thirds of the stuff i'm seeing
is is going to
um get rid of significant numbers of
jobs and i was like well you're
literally
someone who's just staring at uh
the system and and it made sense to me
too intuitively that
the low-hanging fruit for a lot of tech
companies is going to be saving labor
costs because you have to try and show
where your financial returns are going
to come from and imagining that
all of the financial returns are going
to come from these you know blue sky
i mean it made much more sense to me
that you could
uh replace phil and then and then there
are a million fills
um and that's enough to grow some very
very significant companies
um so we all had our moments kevin uh
and um i just want to dig into something
you just said which is interesting so
you're a new york times tech reporter
and you go to conferences um like how
does that work are you like hey i want
to go to this conference
[Laughter]
and then when you get there are you
media like uh like did people react to
you like they're just pitching you their
stuff because they want
uh publicity for their company it works
a lot of ways i mean this was
pre-coveted obviously when there
actually were conferences now i just
show up on zoom
um but pre-covered you know i would go
because i was covering it or there was a
talk i wanted to hear
or i was on a panel or speaking um but
conferences are where a lot of this
stuff happens
um at least where it's announced and so
um you know there's a scene in the uh in
the book where i i went to davos which
is like i don't know if you have you
ever been to davos i have not been to
davos kevin
tell us more it is like a trip
so davos is like the i call it the
coachella of capitalism it's like this
you know week-long retreat in the swiss
alps where all these ceos and
billionaires and heads of state get
together
and um you know people celebrities go
and they fly their private jets in it's
like the biggest
most gaudy um you know conference that
basically ever
has existed and um i was i've only been
the one time this was in in 2019 but i
the thing that i was struck by was how
different
the um the conversations that i heard
were that were on the record and off the
record so like during the day
how davos means the masters of the
universe don't sound exactly the same
when a microphone is on
and when they're at the bar kevin no it
was like a total 180 and maybe i'm naive
because i was just shocked but like
during the day they would have all these
panels
and they would talk about you know oh
we're doing human-centered automation to
you know free up workers and bring in
you know prosperity and this is going to
be great for everyone
and then at night i would like go to
these dinners and i would sit next to
you know the ceo of some fortune 500
company
and he'd be like grilling the guy next
to him who you know worked at some tech
company about like how can i get rid of
my back office and it was really
stark um and really frightening how
eager
the corporate executives were to just
get rid of as many people as possible
and like the that you know this but the
classic comeback the classic thing that
people say is well you know technology
has
always gotten rid of jobs but it always
creates more jobs
and so i started looking at that and
found that that that really the evidence
for that just really isn't there this
time
so lazy man it infuriated me again
people are supposed to be
pretty analytical would just bust [ __ ]
out on me and i'd be like look if
someone walked into your office
um and busted out 120 year old fact
pattern on you you'd like throw them out
you'd be like well i've got some like
you know i've got like a buggy whipped
case study
you'd be like oh i should invest for
sure like the whole thing just struck me
as so
uh self-serving and ridiculous and lazy
you could ratchet like i did get that
an awful lot um that's quite dark
that the but not surprising to me again
that the conversations in private were
so
different from the panels give us some
more davos dirt
uh kevin it'll be fun oh my god yeah it
it's hilarious so i was i was there as a
journalist
and the way that davos works is there's
like a it's like a hierarchy of badge
colors
so like if you are like a like a inner
circle like
super elite um you get like one i forget
which color it is it's like a pink badge
or something like
a gold badge or something and then
there's sort of six or seven tiers below
that
and i was like you know press is like
the lowest tier
and so there are a lot of things that
you know you just can't get into as a
journalist
but there are some things that you can
get into and so i i managed to weasel my
way into some
some uh pretty funny uh events but it's
basically
it's this whole sort of do-gooder ethos
and
you know everyone there is you know
interested in humanitarian pursuits and
philanthropy
and like it's sort of um that's the
davos that you see
and then the one that you don't see is
like everyone just getting like
drunk at night and you know gossiping
and and hanging out with celebrities
and it's sort of a big party
[Music]
what is life if you're not trying to
better yourself that's been one of the
hardest things
pandemic is like keeping that growth
mindset and i've found
some fascinating stuff with skillshare
and skillshare
sponsors this episode yang speaks what i
love about it
is that you can take classes on a whole
bunch of different topics
i've been doing more on like
entrepreneurship and just trying to
learn new specific skills so i took a
class on how to use evernote because my
notes are a disaster and evernote's
pretty
cool like app software to organize and
search
your notes so you can't lose them but
the point is there's all these different
things you learn on arts creativity like
instagram freelancing marketing
photography
all this crazy stuff and it's this
online learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore there's actual projects to
create and support a fellow creative
which is pretty cool
so explore your creativity at
skillshare.com and get a free trial of
premium membership it's free pretty
awesome the annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month so it's not
like super pricey compared to some of
these other crazy
online classes you can take so that's
skillshare.com
yang
[Music]
[Applause]
so now we turn to the personal
useful advice you would give to someone
who is looking up
listening to this podcast and saying oh
wow uh
yang has been talking about this for a
while
kevin roos is another person who knows
what's happening on the ground in tech
um so there is cause for concern uh but
kevin's
here with his book to actually try and
guide people in the right direction
um and so you have nine rules uh
that people can follow and i found some
of them to be
really affecting particularly the the
one and you probably know this or
the one around how our phones are
reprogramming our brain
our brains which they are um but the the
first rule you propose is
be surprising social and scarce uh what
do you mean by that
so this rule came out of conversations i
had with people who work on ai
and i went to them and i asked them okay
what can humans do that computers can't
do
like what what is ai just like not very
good at because it seemed to me
that we've sort of that that's where the
future is going to be for us
is we need to do the things that
machines aren't very good at
um and so they told me that basically
there were three categories
of things that ai was pretty terrible at
one is is tasks that are surprising
so artificial intelligence algorithms
machine learning they really like
structured regular problems
so this is why you know they're very
good at playing chess for example
because it has
consistent rules it's sort of a bounded
universe
and it's not the rules are the same
every time they don't change a lot
so humans by contrast we're really good
at doing things that are
surprising that involve sort of new
situations and
and sort of coming up with creative
solutions to chaotic
problems so like an ai would be a
horrible kindergarten teacher because
that's just like a job that like
is all surprises in all chaos and so
that's the first kind of thing i think
we as humans should focus on is doing
things that are not routine and
repetitive
um and so the second category is social
jobs these are pretty safe from
automation
and those are jobs that you know that
you've talked a lot about a lot in your
work but they're the jobs that involve
not making things but making people feel
things
so you know your nurses your therapists
your your
you know your your clergy your teachers
but also jobs that are are not we don't
think of as being sort of social jobs
but that have a strong social component
like bartenders
i suspect that if even if there are
robot bartenders
who can pour drinks you know it's the
reason you like going to a bar is not
because the drinks are so good it's
because you get to talk to humans and
that's a big part of what makes that job
um hard to automate and then the third
category would be scarce jobs which are
jobs that are basically
um you know involve rare skills
combinations of skills people who are
excellent at their
in their fields and also jobs that sort
of
you really really need them to be done
right the first time there's not a whole
lot of margin for error
so an example of this is the you know
when you call 9-1-1
to report an emergency a human picks up
the phone
and it's not because we don't know how
to automate those jobs it's because
when you're in trouble you don't want to
have to wade through a phone menu you
want to talk to a human right away
and so those are the jobs that we've
sort of decided as a society
should be done by humans even if
machines can do them just as well one of
the categories that
i talked about on the trail is a
non-routine
manual and i made a couple of examples i
said look
you're not going to have an edward
scissorhands robot virtually ever
you know it's like you don't think of
hairdresser or stylist
um as something um that obviously
involves like like a ton of
um education or credentialing but it's
very very safe and resilient
uh because of some of the social aspects
you're talking about but also
um just that you know like there are a
lot of non-routine
uh manual jobs that will be with us for
quite some time and a lot of them do
have a social
component and maybe there's some
surprise involved with them too
yeah i mean one one job that i i sort of
am fascinated by is the um
the barista i mean this is a job that
should have been automated
60 years ago um it's you know we all
have machines called coffee makers in
our house
they make pretty good coffee and so you
would expect that you know coffee shops
that sold coffee would be
you know a sort of dying breed and yet
in any
major city there's a coffee shop on
every corner and why is that it's
because it's not actually just about the
coffee it's about
the human interaction the connection the
talking to people the sort of atmosphere
and it's an experience rather than a
purchasing a good
your next suggestion is to resist
machine drift
um and this is about how machines are
kind of guiding our behaviors in
different ways
yeah so machine drift is the name that i
gave to this feeling that i kept having
i'm you know i'm i'm you made it up
kevin machine drift is your thing we can
like make it a thing yeah we could sell
merch
the idea was that there are all these
ways in which we are being sort of
subtly influenced by
non-human forces so you know i
am a tech writer i have so many gadgets
in my house
i use every app that is dangerous man
because then you justify yourself like
oh it's my job
exactly so every day i you know i wake
up i check twitter i
talk to you know my uh my uh my
alexa i play my spotify playlist that's
automatically generated so i'm
interacting with like probably a dozen
ais like before i have my morning cup of
coffee
and um and a few years ago i started
realizing like
this wasn't really making me happier or
more efficient what it was doing is like
changing my behavior and my preferences
and i would you know i would get uh i
subscribe to this like
algorithmic wardrobe service this is
like pretty dystopian but there are you
know there are these services where you
know they're very popular go and and
they'll you know you put in your
dimensions
and your sizes and they you know analyze
your style and then they send you a box
of sort of clothes that were picked out
by an algorithm and you
so i was like letting it i i did that
for a while and i was letting an
algorithm dress me
and i would have these moments where i
was like i don't even like the way this
thing looks but i'm wearing it because
the algorithm told me to
so it was a real moment of like i have
drifted towards
these machines how are you to put your
taste above the algorithm kevin come on
was that shirt picked out for you by it
by an algorithm
um this shirt was picked out for me um
months ago by someone who worked on my
campaign and now i've got a dozen of
them and so i just wear the same shirt
all the time it's really not great
but it wasn't an algorithm it was a
human nice yeah triumphant humanity
andrew's uh you know ubiquitous blue
shirt
exactly so this was sort of the the
[Music]
the way in for me to talk about this
this sort of sensation of
algorithmic influence i think i think a
lot of us have had that drift feeling i
mean the the
most straightforward time is when you're
just like you know on youtube or some
site and just keeps feeding you stuff
and you're just like
[Laughter]
totally yeah no and and it's also it's
not just about clothes and
you know youtube videos it's like this
is affecting our politics this is
affecting you know
how we use the concept of ourselves um
it's affecting our identities and so um
the reason i
wanted to address this in in the book is
because i think that
in order to be more human which is what
i think we need to do
um when machines take over more and more
of
of the things we used to do um but in
order to be more human we have to know
what we're trying to preserve you have
to know who you actually are
what you actually believe what
preferences are actually yours and which
were put there by instagram and amazon
and
that's very deep my friend very profound
i know so so that's my attempt to say
like
we should we have to like get ourselves
under control like put your put your own
oxygen mask on first
um that's sort of the the approach that
i'm taking
wow and so um one of the uh
oxygen masks you suggest is to try to
uh discipline your device usage and
and you wrote a story that apparently
caught fire where you talked about
trying to
change your relationship with your
smartphone in particular which i can
understand why it's so popular because i
think a lot of us have
a relationship with our smartphone that
we are not excited about
yeah i mean this was written before that
part was written before kovid
um and it's funny i was reading back
through it the other day and um
there's a statistic in there where i
said i was i was you know
expressing my horror at the fact that i
was
on my phone for six hours a day
according to my screen time statistics
and
like i feel like that that no longer
registers as alarming because during the
pandemic we're all on our screens much
more than that
but this is also a piece of of the sort
of
future-proofing yourself because you
know it's not about how much you use
your phone but it is about how much
power you delegate to your phone
um i remember when i got my first
smartphone it was a blackberry
and it was cool it was like a tool it
was like you could use it for all kinds
of things
um but now with how sophisticated our
smartphones are like every time you open
your smartphone and you
open a social media app or or or you use
it
in any way like there are billions of
dollars in r d
and you know dozens of phds and
artificial intelligence who are
pointing a super computer right at you
and trying to influence what you think
and believe and how you act
and so putting the phone back in its
rightful place
as an assistant rather than a boss is uh
is part of what i'm trying to encourage
people to do here one of the things i
adopted a while ago was sleeping in a
different room as my cell phone which is
something you recommend as well
but you had more recommendations than
that um like uh
have a rubber band uh on the phone um to
try and introduce friction
like what were the other steps yeah so
the rubber band was
was first and that doesn't you know that
doesn't really change
anything about the phone but it does
make it a little harder to use
um which is sort of the point just to
kind of notice it
and i worked with a phone coach i had a
woman named catherine price who
is sort of an expert in phone detoxes
and so she was sort of my personal uh uh
you know guru on this what what is her
website because there's some people
listening to this that are like i
totally want to do this
yeah well her book is called um how to
break up with your phone
and uh it's a great book and she's got
another one out now that's called
screen life balance and she's amazing
and she really helped me sort of
recognize how big a problem i had
and and then you know go through the
steps to fix it
but it's really about using your phone
not necessarily less but just in a more
mindful way and not just to reaching for
it because you're bored or you're
you can't be alone with your thoughts
well i had one experience that certainly
uh hit me which is that i was with my
family which when i was running for
president was like a very rare thing but
then you know like that this was
after i came off the trail and then i
saw something on social media
that bothered me and put me in a bad
mood
and then when i was doing something with
my kids i like wasn't enjoying it
properly because
of the thing and then i was like wait a
minute what is going on here like i'm
letting
like this thing i saw on social media on
my phone like
mess with my family time in a way that
frankly when i was on the trail i would
have like
you know like given anything to have
this kind of family time because i was
away so much
and then here i was like misusing it
because of some something like that
someone i never met like
like and that really hit home for me i
was like okay i'm gonna have to change
my ways here because like you know this
is unacceptable
um i think a lot of folks if you haven't
had that kind of experience kudos to you
[Laughter]
but i feel like a lot of people can
relate to that yeah i mean one of the
things that catherine my phone coach
told me
that really stuck with me is she said
your life
is what you pay attention to and i think
about that all the time because i think
we have
really devalued our own attention um
you know we look at our phones hundreds
of times a day they tell us what to
think you know when to think it they
sort of they they are our
ultimate task schedulers um and
i think there's a process that a lot of
us have gone through of realizing
exactly what you realize which is like
oh i am not in control of my own
attention anymore and trying to get some
of that back is is part of what i think
we
need to do now there's another term in
your book that i enjoyed called fubbing
which is short for phone snubbing
um which is when you're with a loved one
but you're just staring at your phone
instead of your loved one
um which i will confess like has
happened uh occasionally in
uh the yang household um so i think
that's another
um yellow flag for someone when like you
look over at your loved one
uh or they look at you and you're both
just heads down totally and that's it's
not just
like rude although it is definitely like
rude and
and like people you know rightly call me
on it including my wife when i do it
but it's also depriving us of these kind
of emotional
skills that we need to build in order to
distinguish ourselves from
machines there have been studies that
find that you know people who
even just having your phone on the table
um
next to you when you're having a meal
with someone even if it's not ringing
even if
even if it's on do not disturb just even
having it there
like dramatically reduces your ability
to listen
and it decreases your enjoyment of the
time that you're spending with that
person
[Music]
all right this podcast is brought to you
by liquid iv i had this this morning i
had the watermelon flavor
why i was tired i had a glass of wine
with dinner
i'm 33 years old and it makes me way
more hungover than i should be
so i took a little bit of water i poured
in some liquid iv mixed it all up
pounded it and i felt great
this stuff is awesome you get more
energy a little bit of caffeine
a ton of vitamins it's just like
injecting your system with
water and you don't get the crash like
you do when you're hammering yourself
with coffee
or things like that so there's matcha in
there ginger there's all this amazing
antioxidants that make
things great improve your mood and your
focus i use it all the time specifically
today
before recording this so grab your
energy liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco heyo love costco or
get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
code yang y-a-n-g as you know
at check-out that's 25 off anything
when you use your promo code yang at
liquidive.com so start fueling your
adventure today
liquidity.com promo code yang
[Music]
[Applause]
one of the the principles you you put
out is to
uh leave handprints which i enjoyed this
was like trying to leave an imprint that
um like the the machine couldn't uh
trying to
humanize something that you're doing um
and this i think could help a lot of
people
um keep their roles from being
automated by trying to see where they
can actually inject more humanity
yeah this was one of the biggest
questions i had going
in was like what are people doing you
know
because there are there are people whose
jobs frankly should have been automated
all throughout history um but they never
were for some reason and so those kind
of like unlikely survivors
and i wanted to try to find their
stories and figure out what had actually
allowed them to keep
their jobs and their relevance and even
as technology you know
supposedly made them obsolete and so i
started finding a lot of stories like
that from you know people who
were you know uh you know 18 you know
19th century factory workers and and
and people who you know survived the
industrial revolution
um people in car factories in the 1960s
who
were able to survive that and then i
found people who
were doing that kind of thing today like
the example i use in the book is
is my accountant um and you know if you
think of accountants you think that job
probably got automated because turbo
tax you know made made it obsolete and
but he's
thriving and one of the reasons he's
thriving is that he's a former stand-up
comedian
and he hires other accountants who are
former comedians and entertainers
and he pays for them all to get improv
comedy classes
and because he thinks it makes them
better at relating to clients and as a
result like
it's really fun to do your taxes like
people do not believe me when i say that
i have fun talking with my accountant
well the funniest thing is that his name
is actually funny i was like brass taxes
was that
yeah it's brass taxes and um and
you know he's just a great example of
how you can
stay afloat in an industry that has been
rapidly automated in the most boring
industry alive
by by being a human and that's i think
what's happening to people in a lot of
fields is they're having to lean more on
their human skills because
you know just being a talented
accountant probably isn't enough
to to keep you relevant just being a
talented
you know radiologist in the future you
know when ai is reading all of our
all of our scans being a talented
radiologist
is not going to cut it you'll also have
to bring some human skills to the table
so
i think we need to work on those skills
because what happened to
accountants is going to happen to
journalists and
professors and artists um there are no
sort of robot proof jobs i had an
experience on the trail that just
reminded me of kevin
um where i was running for president um
most people
were ignoring me at that
um and that every once in a while when
we had a breakthrough
um it would be because i did something
very human
sometimes something that i frankly found
like uncomfortable
or um embarrassing um but then
um if it happened enough
then i started you know obviously
adapting um
and i'll actually describe this to you
because you probably don't know this so
i uh start running for president 2018
and it is a slog like no one cares no
one's paying attention
a lot of people are kind of bemused uh
we're not able to raise much money
like you know very very limited press
and a lot of it is because in 2018 no
one was talk
uh talking about the presidential
election so i was like you know way way
ahead of the curve it was very difficult
and then in 2019 we started doing better
um
and there were a number of kind of uh
social media moments that some people
might remember
one was me crowd surfing another one was
me doing the cupid shuffle
uh and and there were other things that
genuinely at the time i was like
a little bit uncomfortable about where i
was like uh well you know like i seem
like kind of a goof
but then i would do a major news
interview
and they would just be asking me about
that and not
whatever you know policy platform i'd
put out
um and so you know again you start
adapting
um and and so i think i can actually
relate somewhat to what you're arguing
for about
trying to lean into your humanity
because
when i was on the trail and i was trying
to be all
uh frankly um you know putting out very
big ideas and policies out there
people wouldn't pay as much attention
than if i was
um you know like jazzer sizing or or
whatever the heck it um
like the example is yeah totally and i
remember from your campaign i mean i
i remember during one of the debates um
you were up there
and and you were you know up there with
a lot of the other sort of democrats in
the primary and i
a friend who knew that i knew you um
texted me and it says like he seems like
the only human up there
because you know you weren't like super
polished you didn't you know you weren't
like giving well rehearsed like you were
you were saying things that were
that were you know grammatically correct
and and
and true for the most part but like but
like you weren't
it wasn't like you were reading off a
teleprompter and
so much of of what i think made your
candidacy appealing to people was that
you were able to just kind of like talk
like a human and and act like a human
and not some like you know political
automaton like built in a lab
and i think that's really instructive
for for not just people running for
office but for people in all kinds of
fields
um yeah i think you're ability to sort
of
be a human and talk like a human and
relate to people like a human is is
really
um an underrated uh thing and it's
really it's it's not easy to do when
everyone's you know trying to
train that out of you but you you were
able to do it
yeah it was an adaptation it took me
about a year uh because
you know necessity is the mother of
invention and all that
[Laughter]
but i'm really glad your friend said you
that i mean that's that's super
gratifying
[Music]
[Applause]
all right i just got my new and i've
said this before so i've got my second
new helix mattress because i like the
first one got another one
helix matches are like sleeping on the
pillow
if you will like a massive pillow
they're so freaking comfortable and i
got a king so it's like
literally swimming in it so you go
online you take a two minute quiz
talk about how you sleep which way you
sleep on your back on your side
and then you find a mattress that they
have that works for
you and it's so awesome but you don't
take my word for it because
helix was aborted number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine if you go to
helix.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
they'll match you to a customized
mattress and give you the best sleep of
your life i can say that with authority
because i love
my mattress they have a 10 year warranty
you get to try
it out for a hundred nights it's totally
risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it so here's the deal helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com
slashing for up to 200 off and two free
[Music]
pillows
there was an another idea in your book
that was very very important i thought i
mean a lot of important ideas
you can tell um but one was about
people innovating better when they're
physically proximate to each other
and so you quote a number of people the
ceo of adobe
chantin narayan says that when you're
trying to create a new project you want
people around that water cooler
and there was a study that
said that even academics tended to
produce
better research when they were located
uh closer to each other and i thought
this was such like a an important
counter argument to like the zoom moment
wherein
um and apparently you'd even written a
bunch of a chapter that you then had to
rewrite or discard because
of covid when you were like you know
in-person collaboration is where it's at
um but would love for you to unpack a
bit about
um what you found on how people
uh are the most productive or happy uh
in terms of uh work environments yeah
well there's
the chapter you talked about was was um
in the pre-coveted version of the book
and and it was all about how sort of
remote work is a trap for workers
because
um it's a trap when you say that it's
like like
you know star wars well yeah so the
research is actually fairly clear on
this question
um studies have found over and over
again that remote workers are
more productive than people in an office
on average in part because you know
they're not spending two hours a day
commuting they're not distracted you
know
it's it's much easier to be productive
when you're at home i guess
we should say like this was before covet
where people's kids were crawling all
over them and stuff but
in general workers who work from home um
are more productive but they're less
creative
it's harder for them to sort of
collaborate on big projects to come up
with new ideas
and this has been known in the corporate
world for a long time it's why
you know google and apple and facebook
and all these tech companies that
literally build the tools that
remote workers use they have giant
corporation
offices in silicon valley where tens of
thousands of people come to work
every day again pre-covered and that's
because
they understand that good ideas come in
many cases from these kind of random
collisions between people
from being in the same place thinking
about things sitting in conference rooms
together
and the kind of moments between meetings
that's where a lot of the sort of
innovation happens
so i think that's part of what worries
me about this shift to remote work
that we're seeing now with covid is it
seems
to be working for some people but like i
feel less creative
when i'm at home than when i'm in a
newsroom with you know my colleagues
making phone calls and
you know talking over you know talking
and i can hear their conversations and
it might strike some idea
and so i think remote workers have to be
very careful not to let themselves get
sort of dehumanized by that process and
there are some tips in the book for how
to do that but i think that's really
important because
in a sense like remote remote workers
are kind of halfway automated already um
and so i think wow that's such a
powerful statement well i mean think
about it it's like you
are visible to your team mostly as sort
of a name in their inbox or a slack
you know username the way to measure
your productivity
is by like the number of tasks you
complete and you
miss out on a lot of those kind of like
moments between tasks the you know the
experience of being in an office of
making relationships of you know
building
trust of mentoring people the kind of
softer
parts of the office experience are
actually really really important
um so i think workers including me who
are working remotely right now are going
to have some sort of
rehumanizing to do when when all this is
over and we can go back to the office
so you hear that people when the heads
of various departments are like hey want
you back in the office
like don't reflexively be like no no no
like maybe heading back is actually
maybe they're looking out for you
maybe by having you back in the office
you're going to have
all different ways to add value that
would not be possible over zoom
huh i mean i i genuinely believe this
because i've been in a number of
organizations and the argument i make
which is very similar to the argument
you're making though
you're you're making it and yours is
based on data um
around the fact that creative
collaborative work is just
better in person and studies bear that
out the thing that i'm
arguing for is somewhat similar which is
that it's very hard to build a culture
remotely and if you're going to try and
cultivate
younger workers and have them become
important parts of your org and then
eventually become managers and leaders
i think you need to have them in the
office uh you know i i
think that um someone joked with me and
said it's very hard to get promoted over
zoom
yep totally and i think that's what i've
been hearing from remote workers since
the pandemic started
i mean obviously we should say like
people should not rush back to the
office until it's safe to do so and all
the vaccines are out
um like there's no reason to jeopardize
your safety to to go to an office but i
do think
a lot of companies are gonna find that
maybe they didn't come up with as many
new
innovations during the pandemic maybe
their maybe their creativity suffered a
little bit maybe they're not um
you know having as many sort of
breakthroughs um
and i think that's going to be really
interesting to see how many companies
sort of
stay mostly remote and how many
companies
come back to the office and which of
them do better
yeah i genuinely think there's going to
be a competitive advantage over time
to organizations that have more
face-to-face proximity
um to me a lot of it really is about
where you are in your career where if
you're a bit older
and you've kind of gotten stuff down and
then you feel like okay i can beam in
remotely and get stuff but again if
you're younger and developing
i think meeting in person and working in
person
is vital to how people's careers grow
and develop
and i think that a lot of this
discussion is kind of
misleading because a lot of people are
doing the discussion are frankly in the
first
category where they're kind of more
mature totally and so that so they talk
about it like hey i can just
zoom in it's like well sure but you've
been at your job for 18 years
totally and i'm thinking about you know
when i started off as a journalist and
so much of how i learned was just by
watching over people's shoulders by
you know grabbing them in the in the
lunch line and saying hey how did you do
that
thing you know in that paragraph like
just the sort of subtle people watching
that you get to do in an office and
i i'm not sure how i would have gotten
those skills if i had just been at home
you know typing into a laptop we're
grateful that you are where you are
kevin
uh your last big principle i i uh
thought was super important i just want
you to to unpack it it's called
arm the rebels what the heck do you mean
by arm the rebels
kevin bruce well i uh it's not as
violent as it sounds
um i'm a pacifist uh so i i chose
that language um sort of carefully but
i i think that one of the ways that we
who are not technologists can
support the development of ethical um
and huma and humanizing technology is by
supporting the people inside the tech
industry
who are working to make it better um
there are a lot of examples of this you
know people
at google and amazon and facebook
you know rank and file workers who are
trying to do the right thing
and there are also people who are sort
of in the tech industry
even if they're not in the sort of
biggest companies who are doing
startups that are public good startups
that are trying to sort of steer
technologies like ai in a more humane
direction there are
you know activists who are trying to you
know get the
use of facial recognition software by
law enforcement um
you know banned or sort of prohibited at
a kind of state
level um and i think these are important
people in the whole picture of
technology i think often we
we think you know we forget that those
people are there and
um and they don't get as much attention
as the jeff bezos is and the elon musk's
but they're
they're super important and so i think
arming the rebels means
figuring out who those people are and
supporting them with what they need
whether it's
you know fundraising or attention
it's why i try to bring attention to
some of those people in my times column
because i think it's really important
that there'd be incentives for people to
to do this stuff trying to do the right
thing because there's so much money and
frankly doing things as they're
currently done
so anyone who's trying to go against
that grain is really really
swimming against a very powerful current
yeah absolutely but they're there
well that so that's hopeful uh you
talked to
hundreds of people in tech um like
what proportion of them fall into this
category where you see them as
uh activists who are trying to improve
things
uh i don't i don't know how to put a
number on it but i i think if i
you know i think it it can be hard
to identify them because i think a lot
of the executives have learned how to
talk like
they are ethical technologists um but
you really have to look at
actions i mean one of the one of the
principles i i
look at in the book is this idea of
consequentialism
of sort of me the the need for
technologists to kind of measure
their success not based on how they
intended their products to work but on
how their products actually work out in
the world well right now they're
measuring how their products uh
performing by engagement and how much
money they're making i don't even know
if there's like
like how it's supposed to work
measurement right right but when they're
challenged when you say you know mark
zuckerberg your you know
your news feed algorithm is is you know
tearing society apart or leading to more
polarization
the fallback response is always well you
know we built this with good intentions
and what i'm trying to tell people is
like it doesn't matter like
your intentions are it's good that if
they're good
but what ultimately matters is how this
technology is applied out in the world
and
you know it's a very strange standard
man like if i'm a doctor
and then i do something messed up and
then you know it's like
like whatever i operate on the wrong leg
and then they would be like hey that was
the wrong leg being well i intended it
to be the right leg
that's not exactly like a compelling uh
argument in just about any field
right but you hear that all the time in
tech and i think it's really ingrained
in them that as long as you have good
intentions
your job is just to create the
technology and how people use it is up
to them
uh that is not great
yeah i mean they definitely should be um
measuring uh impact and then say like
hey is this impact working or not
working
certainly i'm very passionate about a
lot of the the stuff you're writing
about in part because i can see the
impact as uh
being very negative in some respects and
you can see it with the
eroding mental health of various people
particularly teenage girls in response
to
some of the the social media apps that
we're using um and you'll never see that
show up in anyone's financial statement
um but it's it's
destructive and devastating to certain
uh people in certain families
they're they're growing negative
externalities with a lot of our use of
technology that again
like we're not measuring correctly if
you were to incorporate that measurement
then things would look different
but these tech companies um as you're
say
as you're describing like don't feel
themselves be particularly culpable for
some of the negative externalities
because they're like well
you know we wanted to build something
awesome we made a lot of money uh
and and if there's something less than
awesome going on um
you can like we can make some uh good
sounding
noises at like a panel and then all will
be well and you're just like well that
didn't really solve the problem
yeah well i i i'm actually like more
optimistic on this front than i used to
be and
and i i think because i'm meeting so
many of these
sort of rebels um i i know that there
are people who are pushing for
for change in a good direction and
historically i
for this book i went back and i read a
lot about the first industrial
revolution the second industrial
revolution the third industrial
revolution
and in each of those there were people
who were agitating
to make humans lives better as a result
of this new technology and not just
use it to enrich executives and
shareholders
there are people in every technological
age who are not
anti-tech it doesn't mean being
anti-tech doesn't mean being
anti-automation
it doesn't mean being a luddite what it
means is
all these technologies can improve
humans lives or they can make them worse
and there are people
in the industry and outside of the
industry who are trying to make the best
version
of this technology for the age that
we're living in and that's coming up
well kudos to you for being one of the
conscientious voices
uh that in your case i mean you cover
the tech industry but uh
you you in many ways represent uh the
way a lot of people will understand the
tech industry given your
prominence as one of the foremost tech
journalists the new york times
so the book is future proof nine rules
for humans in the age of
automation and kevin you have your own
podcast
um if people want to follow you and all
of your learnings
where where can they go well they can go
to my website kevinroots.com or there's
a
special website just for the book called
futureproofthebook.com
and you can follow him on social media
he's a very good follow he's constantly
sharing
uh nuggets of insight about what's
coming down the pike
i learned a lot from kevin roose i hope
you did too on this podcast thank you
kevin i appreciate the heck out of you
and thank you for
this massive contribution with this book
may it help many many people
thank you so much it's really it's a
pleasure to talk
[Music]
you